world's only talking about like sales
jobs and things like that like
like what about in the hospital
that's what's there yeah
[Music]
in a recent study
attractive female students no longer
earned higher grades when classes moved
online during covet 19.
why because they want to [__] into
teachers
like little animals or something
is that why this affirms my narrative
bro
that's my name I knew it was crazy
yeah they can't get extra credit because
it's not blowing the professors well no
the professors don't find them hot and
they're not scared to give them like
that worse grades because they turn
their cameras off and maybe she won't
[__] me eventually or maybe hot girls
got so depressed that their grades got
lower because they couldn't study yeah
that's it no what the [__] you guys have
no sympathy for hot girls we don't
where's your heart we don't new
psychology findings suggests that
attractive students can earn higher
grades in school but for female students
his Beauty premium disappears when
classes are taught remotely a large body
of research suggests that physical
appearance has an impact on a person's
success agree or disagree hell yeah of
course because you [__] attract
attention you're free marketing yeah
absolutely Attractive people tend to
earn more money report higher life
satisfaction
um Scholars have yet to agree on the
explanation behind the beauty premium
yeah I guess skulls are pretty good you
need a scholar to explain her I'm sure
they're the hottest Scholars ever
that's why for me and Scholars it's on
site
right away dude oh what's your job a
scholar you call yourself a scholar I've
been waiting for this day
calls themselves that you know those the
cheeses so you know that stereotype
about like hot people being dumb right I
think this is my this is my this is my
reasoning for why that came to be right
so hot people in general attract the
most attention so all eyes are on them
right that most people are just stupid
so because most people are just dumb
regardless of your good looking or not
it just magnifies the stupidity in human
beings so then you think oh hot people
are stupid but most people are [__]
stupid that's a fact but they don't get
attention my theory oh please please
also hot people they get the attention
and they get the rewards so they don't
apply themselves afterwards because it's
too easy that's true hot privilege
that's what I was gonna say it's like
hot people like you can be a hot chick
right and you're like I'm doing a little
bit of math and then people like you're
like really [__] smart smartest
person I've ever met
just a little bit of math yeah just oh
just don't do that or like you tell like
a pretty boring story which by the way
hot people tend to do I think with no
end the [__] boring stories and then
it's like and then it's like oh wow
that's the most deep and [__]
interesting story I've ever heard I hope
we have sex soon in a way that it is
kind of unfair to them because all their
jokes are bangers everything they say is
like smart incredible and you think
everyone's so nice you get an incorrect
gauge of where they stand it's pretty
it's pretty rough like hot girls who end
up doing comedy they don't know if
they're really funny and they they're
almost aren't most aren't most aren't
most aren't and then when they're she's
at it they're getting a lot of sympathy
laughs but then when they go to a real
crowd at some point which always happens
then that's when it gets real people are
like I'm probably not gonna [__] her she
can't even see me there's like a lot of
lights
and so they're just actually just
they're just the online version of class
actually reviewing it just reviewing it
yeah so is it really hot privilege if
your life is so miserable I think you
get the shot like you're more likely to
get the opportunities I think to a
certain point until you're not hot me
that's true because raise your hand if
you met somebody who [__] their way
into a position of power
I like that yours stays up
I mean I don't know if I know anyone
like that I personally have done it
especially yes yes yes oh yeah think
about me know so many people how could
you not think about the tubers that you
know come on those are the ones to think
of it always is the tubers it's always
tubers tubers and actors is that what
you did me yeah [__] my way
for men we lick our way yeah exactly
that's a suck machine
no but I I it's just a thing right like
I've met so many people and you know
this is obviously one of those it's just
a thing where like the guy and this
happens with the girls too like the
girls meet the guy and then the guy
blows up later happens much less though
the Guy meets some girl
right and then like they get strung
along into the world and then they get
[__] tons of views dumped on their heads
and then they get a presence from that
and all I had to do is like a little bit
of [__] and sucking barely even for
like you know a year or two like Pete
Davidson well Pete Davidson's gonna you
know he's crushing it he's got a golden
[__] I heard yeah yeah yeah somehow
everything dude he's he's with Emily
I think I think you don't understand why
these women find them attractive
I just do not get it if we put you like
he's not even funny no absolutely you
don't even think he's funny but maybe
you gotta Be A Millionaire woman to
understand it's a hit or miss but
overall to know I think if we put you in
a room with them you'd walk out married
married and limping
yeah it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna happen it's not gonna happen with
him because you don't trust yourself in
a room with him yeah
I wouldn't either because it's
absolutely not not gonna happen uh what
about Pete Wentz oh my God who's it
absolutely gonna happen with yeah don't
worry about it what if he's doing that
was good what if he's in character as
chat his SNL classic character okay sick
that's him he goes cool that's it that's
the whole bit Yeah that's the bit yeah
it's a classic there's got to be a cap
though for like what the [__] happened
to you when hot I can't process your
emotions right now you guys are so new
here this is very normal [__] how about
now all right there's guys I like the
other one better though
yeah yeah yeah there's gotta be a cap
here where there's probably at some
point looks don't matter
I think looks you know it's weird and
what I mean by that specifically is like
when it comes to being an Olympian
that's not going to help you through the
door I just needed help
well as in like your looks aren't going
to help you jump higher you know you
don't have to jump as high
it's true dude you don't have to be the
best Olympian to be successful because
most Olympians are trying to be
successful after the Olympics no I'm
talking about only in the race so like
they're looking at the the stats of the
race so you're talking about in the one
category that's supremely physical well
yeah because or in in business like the
numbers don't lie like you could be hot
or ugly it doesn't matter like you have
to make money for your business right so
then it's a skill set oh business is
yeah that's a good one right or like
things that require you to use whatever
skills and maybe yeah what what you I
don't know it's just different from just
looks oh but then business is also
[__] you'll probably close the deal
you can but you still have to maintain
the deal or like so it might be an
initial good like it I mean it does come
with benefits of you could grab an
attention but now how do you maintain
that it's like winning the law who
doesn't though because some people
like Steve said himself I think they're
just stupid they're just so dumb that
why would you want to do a business deal
with them
I said I just like throw and Steve and
Steve in the mix you know it's actually
Joe Joe's actually the one but is it the
answer then to be the the figurehead
that's attractive and then you just hire
dumb smart people or not dumb ugly smart
people
nobody wants to hire them though no it's
the ugliest ugly smart people run the
business and then they hire the face of
the business that's the way to do it oh
like in Asia yeah they hire like a
[__] British guy to be the yeah the
CEO typing like this dude hella hot
people are in real estate that's true
because it's hard to say no yeah to that
deal I can't wait to say no that's
they're almost just gonna add that as
the next tier of uh NBA cheerleader you
just pretty much go straight to Re Max
but we're all only talking about like
sales jobs and things like that like
like what about in the hospital
worthless there yep that's why they all
become only fans girls so they dip out
they bone out yeah they can't they find
a doctor they married ones in the
hospital get hired to be in Hollywood
movies where they play roles in the
hospital
I figured Emergency Services would be a
place where it doesn't matter who's hot
but look at [__] firefighters are
they classically hot are you [__]
kidding yeah call 9-1-1 right now start
a fire in this room right now who shows
up I feel like lifeguards and
firefighters yeah dude you feel like
firefighters are pretty dreamy Colleen
yeah
there you go what about firefighters
that are dressed like Pete Davidson he
was a firefighter in the movie
firefighters dressed like he did
it's not the other way I think I'm
starting to change my mind here he's got
a bunch of fake tattoo he knew it
fake sleep it's just the way you say it
I don't know you can't even tell it's a
firefighter yeah he's like where's fire
wait who are you who are you not
certified yeah I'm PJ is it Emily
radakowski yeah for real yeah he's going
through there's nobody he won't get he's
getting Giselle next dude dude yeah
he'll get yourself no giselle's already
dating somebody oh I heard she's dating
a jiu jitsu guy yeah wow
look how Nick withholds information like
that you withhold it why did you do that
Nick we're a news channel don't hold
back that's why I think it's it's about
time all these news outlets stop being
shocked that P Davidson's getting those
like why don't you just finally adopt
that must be the modern hot guy thank
you probably [__] time he's gonna
make people's hottest guy ever no the
next one that's why I'm asking who's the
modern hot guys who's worthy of this
credit do you think Pete Davidson come
on guys
saying Kim Kardashian and Emily
Ratajkowski you're like me and Ryan we
are we don't want Christmas music to
play right now but it is there's nothing
we can [__] do about it
yeah I think I think he is the modern
hot guy but I don't think every woman
likes that but no woman likes the modern
hot guy any era
like No Woman No Woman automatically
isn't he just the modern hot guy to [__]
not to like stay with no all around he's
today's like I don't know I'm not making
the rules up he's just two days there
had to be [__] he was like James D
ugh yeah for sure Marlon Brando gross
like that happened every time losers
he's a heartthrob but this dude's like
we have a [__] scientist was
analyzing him the undeniable proof yeah
Clint Eastwood oh God finally how who
does he have to [__] to prove himself to
you how about that how about that like
it's not about Gal Gadot he's coming for
her we know he [__] it's just it's just
a matter of time because you okay you
guys remember in the 90s he doesn't
think he's attractive no not at all do
you guys remember I that that's a thing
but remember in the 90s [__] Fabio
was the Fabio and we all laughed at that
[__] but we didn't get it at least I
understood we only laughed because you
couldn't believe it wasn't buttered yeah
that's true but then like when you see
Fabio though and he's riding that horse
with his shirt off it's ridiculous but I
get it yeah I get it I get it it's valid
that like most people like there are
good people are like that is so
hilarious and gross but it's like hey
but with Pete Pete Davidson I get it for
17 year old girls not Kim Kardashian
how old's Ariana Grande he had her he
has Emily Rada
he has [__] Kim K I mean and then
next Colleen L yeah
all three of those ladies those are all
rebounds
Pizza rebound oh he's a rebound boy so
he's a rebound boy so he's he's just a
[__] and then Kim Kim left Kanye I never
said he wasn't strategic just yeah
that's true the [__] and the rebound not
the relationship yeah right it's still a
note
so who is the relationship what do we
have to do to get you to [__] Pete
Davidson
he's worthy we swear I'm gonna hire a
team people we're gonna [__] get on
this so so then he's he's just a really
good closer and maybe he's not a good
sustainer I need I need to know who the
best modern man is today yeah I think
it's I think it's Ben Shapiro
I say what I want to say I am who I want
to be I'm going to tell you right now
why I am that guy he's always attacking
words by the end of the sentence Anthony
you will be sucking my dick
okay and if you're not talking about it
Andrew Cleveland
um uh Matt Walsh uh it is like the left
always says
foreign
[Music]